to him here we are it's been an
unbelievable season I'm gonna ask you
the tough questions are you and Jennifer
still together well I can't answer that
but obviously we have one episode left
that errors next Sunday and then we have
the tell-all so the viewers will know a
better idea of kind of what's going on
with our journey then so just you know
stay tuned and you'll know was this
experience what you thought it would be
yeah it was to an extent I don't think I
was quite prepared for how passionate
people are about this show and obviously
the show has just gotten so big the
viewers are you know or just like we
were number one like ten weeks in a row
or something it's just crazy I mean but
uh you know it's being on reality TV I
mean you know you're kind of thrown into
the public limelight overnight so it's a
big adjustment that you have to make
quickly buzzer than that I've just been
kind of rolling with it I mean I love it
you're in very positive mood you're
rolling with it because this is a
passionate fan base and the critiques
fly and you put the most vulnerable
parts of yourself on television it's
been emotional for you at all what's
been hard about it I think you know
there's always gonna be a little bit of
negativity when you're on TV just you
know people see things the way they want
to see it so I get frustrated sometimes
by the way people interpret things just
because obviously for time constraints
you're not able to see the whole story
always but I'm very thrilled that people
are that passionate about the show I
mean I'm a part of it I'm proud to be on
it and for people to get that emotional
and you know excited about it it's like
wow at least you know you would hate to
be on a show that nobody's talking about
what I mean I'd take Tim here we are at
the party for sure so looking back
watching so far anything you would have
done differently there's definitely some
things that I see that like you know
I'll watch and kind of cringe like oh
god I remember I was in a bad mood that
day but otherwise I wanted just to be
filmed being myself and I think that
that was accomplished what you see is me
you know I may be eccentric I may be
weirder than some guys that are out
there but that's me
you know we saw you give Jennifer a ring
you had plans for your ex would you
rethink that one well there's a lot of
you know
story on that ring and a lot more to do
with just what the viewers saw but
obviously I was running out of time yeah
and you know she gave me that ring at a
going-away party I was leaving in like
24 48 hours later so obviously if I'd
have more time maybe I went traded it in
or you know got a different ring but
it's what I had to work with at the end
of day I give it to her you know as a
promise ring so at least you know I can
get our different engagement ring if
that's the path that we end up taking
and then you know it's good to go so you
guys have really been in the spotlight
for kind of the unique relationship also
that you have with your ex why didn't
you two work out because you still
stayed in her daughter's life and your
best friends
you know we were together for most nine
years and we gave it 110% gave it our
best shot just didn't word that wrote
the romantic ship sailed you know what I
mean so now I'm just appreciative she's
a very dear friend of mine and she's in
my mind the mother of my daughter so we
co-parent so a lot of people always say
oh I wish you'd give a together with
your eggs but it's not gonna happen I'll
say that first here you will never read
that in the headlines every one I can
heart back together
still best friend we you know we're best
friends but it's part time if we're both
in relationships you know we get busy
and you know it really just becomes
handing off Chloe you know when I spend
time with her but she's somebody I know
if I need she's there so we also saw
Jennifer well she asked you if you were
gay she said she had that that issue a
drug very direct and you guys have not
slept together so far as we've seen
right what do you say to those
allegations well I mean Jennifer's not
the only one that said that you know
let's be honest there's a lot of people
that have speculated that there's all
kinds of issues going on but what I like
to remind people is you know it's an
invigorating day as a man when you wake
up and you're no longer controlled by
your penis and that wasn't my agenda to
go you know I'm almost 40 years old I
want to be in love you know I know sex
is an important part of love but it's
not everything like it used to be so my
biggest goal was just building a
foundation that I thought would be able
to last because I don't want to be
divorced I've waited this long to get
married never been married you know so
III think that's strange that society
just thinks if a man says no then he's
gay the woman says no it's fine but it's
like the double standard that society
has
I just kind of laugh about it you know I
do have some feminine traits we know the
gay thing which is kind of like out of
left field for me thank you for that
answer I mean that's a really good point
now I'm gonna ask you a tough question
but this is what some people are
speculating because it shows all about
deep secrets some people are saying that
you are hiding a secret that you once
used to be a woman right what do you say
to those people I mean that's laughable
to me you know the episode that just
aired you saw me get into a hot tub with
Jennifer and I saw online people were
literally screenshotting and looking for
scars where I had my breasts removed so
you know again it comes with the
territory you're gonna get people that
just have to come up with these
outlandish ideas but I think it's just
very odd for a lot of women to see a man
that's not rude by a beautiful woman and
you know that is something that is
unique about me I've dated a lot of
pretty girls so they just don't really
it doesn't do it for me as much as it
used to you know if I don't like
something I'm gonna make sure I'm happy
in a good place before I move to that
level because once you have sex the
dynamic of the relationship absolutely
changes so I'm not transgender
I think it's cool for the people that
you know want to do that and that's what
you want to do with your life but that's
not me I love your confidence because
this is some big stuff people are saying
yeah I mean well you know again would
you rather have people say this or does
not say nothing that that's the
predicament you know so at least they're
talking and I feel like in suit you kind
of get I mean you seem like a pretty
confident guy you wear what you want to
wear you do what you want to do does
that attract the ladies um you know I
don't feel like I've ever had a problem
finding a girlfriend but you know I am
Who I am and it took me many years I had
very low self-esteem as a child I was
bullied a lot of the time we didn't have
money you know my mom had three boys and
was a secretary so I've come a long way
I started my own business working my way
up made a little bit of money with able
to buy nice clothes was able to start
dressing nicer and I worked on my
appearance to the best that I could you
know we can all improve but I've done
the best that I can and I'm confident
with that and yeah I'm gonna be who I
want to be if you like it you do if you
don't you don't I mean that's all gonna
have to work that's what Tim has to say
okay that's right do you still talk to
your other ex from Colombia the one who
mommy in your ah no I do not talk and
talk to mommy
I hope mommy is doing well I wish her
the best but you know know that the only
friend that I have that's an ex is
Veronica okay
so positive to my love well you know I
never want to be one of those guys that
just if you date somebody you don't have
to hate them after you're done you know
you can wish each other well and just
realize it didn't work out and just you
know be nice to each other they don't
hate they don't think I like it I love
it so what happens with you and Jennifer
well you have to watch and see yeah
that's cool that you try to try to slide
that right in there but yeah you will
have to watch the show to find it and I
will be watching I'm addicted to it many
of us are yes my last questions for you
sometimes there's drama between the
couples I mean a lot of the times at the
reunion anybody who you're worried about
when you see them in person any couple
who you maybe have something to say - um
well I will say this you know that's how
always coming soon and you do not want
to miss it and that's all I'm gonna say
but it is really freaking good you guys
have taped it what goes down give me a
key I can't say anything but I will say
that they won't surprise me if it's not
the most view tell-all whole time it's
gonna go down in the history book this
wonderful what about adjectives like
volatile crazy it is crazy it is
unexpected it is just gonna blow your
mind and and the people that are
involved with what you're gonna see are
gonna be the least likely suspects last
question you were new to this show what
advice would you give other people
heading into the new season make sure
that you are true to yourself and have
thick skin great style
yeah and great style yeah don't don't be
afraid to just be yourself I mean you
know people people are scared of the
unknown so men that wear knee high
leather boots in college and iPads
that's not normal so people that don't
understand that they just label you but
yeah do what you want to do and
you know some people are gonna like you
somebody were gonna hate you does it
really matter
you look great do you have any other
skin secrets you weren't able to share
on TV no I really to be honest with you
uh I was a smoker for 20 years so it's
amazing that I've been able to keep my
skin looking as good as this but I just
use the iPads and a little bit of face
cream Aaron wants one that's it so yeah
I guess I thank you mom and dad for good
genetics
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]